don't you know me kansas city
i'm the new berlin world try and tear me
down
based on the off-broadway musical about
a genderqueer singer
2001's hedwig in the angry inch may have
been a commercial flop you could give me
a cavity honey
but the film received rave reviews from
critics quickly becoming a fan favorite
with writer director and star john
cameron mitchell earning a slew of award
nominations
including a golden globe nod a hedwig
you know
at its heart is a love story and it's
about finding your other half
for that reason we've had a really
diverse audience and more people than i
expected
you know we're really moved by it
that sarcastic contemptuous tone that
means you know everything because you're
a man
and i know nothing because i'm a woman
you're not a woman
he's also the most entertaining person
in the world to be around so
uh it was just a great deal of fun every
day to go to work
yes it was nathan's on-screen chemistry
with the late robin williams
that made the 1996 remake of the
birdcage an
instant hit bringing in over 185 million
dollars at the box office
the film is filled with a lot of laughs
but also a ton of heart
i mean as long as there's a love it is a
family
whether they're same-sex parents or
heterosexual parents this is my mother
and also to acknowledge you know this
country is all different types of people
and not to deny anybody
same basic human rights i am hereby
stripping you of all your princess
points
i am the prettiest i'm sorry wesley has
a cute butt
and he is the squeeziest and leguizamo
is the easiest but i definitely am the
prettiest and the most sophisticated
most elegant
you are a whole lot of woman yes
starring three of some of the biggest
stars of 1995
to wong fu thanks for everything julie
newmar got plenty of buzz
with the late patrick swayze and john
leguizamo each scoring golden globe noms
for their portrayal of new york city
drag performers
co-star wesley snipes credits the
performances to the real life drag
artists who worked behind the scenes
they take the the old saying that you
know you're not promised tomorrow
seriously so they live for today they
live today very very well and they try
to make it as glamorous as god designed
it for us to be
[Applause]
it doesn't seem fair that only gay
people have to come out why is straight
the default i have something i need to
tell you
i like girls you're trying to kill me i
like men
i'm straight i'm heterosexual oh
god damn it jesus love simon may be the
newest film on our list
but the 2018 movie was the first major
studio rom-com to feature a gay teen as
the lead character
based off the best-selling novel the
film even inspired the tv series
love victor which continues to spark
conversations regarding sexuality
acceptance and inclusion something the
film stars are grateful to have been a
part of
going and talking to different young
kids
and hear how it's helped them feel that
much more validated in what they're
doing in their lives and how they want
to show up on this earth it's been a
really beautiful experience
and coming in at the top of our list the
adventures of priscilla
queen of the desert
yes nuances from the iconic 1994 film
can still be seen in drag culture today
like in rupaul's drag race up next art
simone
and craft simone we knew instantly that
she was doing priscilla
from the costumes to the music to the
story the australian film
offered a more intimate and dignified
representation of the lgbtq plus
community
terence stamp who portrayed bernadette a
transgender woman
told et that he knew he had to be a part
of it from the moment he read the script
it's my first time as a girl it's my
first musical it's
almost my first film comedy it was
wonderful it was
the most fun thing i've ever done in my
career frankly
you